whoo I can't believe we're moving yeah I
think it's times on that porch how do
you you are impossible carve this thing
this is [ __ ] okay hey I have to make
two trips no not to trip how much for
the masterpiece love yard sales this is
my element day okay used to call me VL
closing early cuz I close every deal
yeah I'm unstoppable yo how much for the
painting 300 300 yeah that's a good
movie but how much for the painting 350
now because you said that stupid-ass pun
oh yeah he hates puns Halloween's coming
up and I was thinking of a couple
costume ideas Jumanji it's kind of like
a Jewish Explorer vibe sort of thing we
could do a where wolf like a wet like
where like I don't know I've got a map
and I'm lost
Oh a snarky baby that's handsome maybe
like Josh Kosh Daniel Tosh or I mean we
could keep brainstorming obviously 200
325 throwing the baby of boxing gloves
250
deal drive a hard bargain sir how much
was that for real like five maybe ten
dollars yo that's the game Kate you got
a highest the ball it every time so that
when you come down you still win okay
yeah try it on this guy trate trate
straight hey how much for the lamp $1.00
no come on
400 does it even work I need to know it
works I need to know if it works
okie dokie I think we have a plug in the
backyard I could show you just follow me
are you good out here
yeah me uh yeah I think I got it hurtful
that was my first time haggling okay
it shows right this way sir this must
have been out of here since last year's
Christmas decoration disaster hey focus
I don't have any time for your stories
Shh come to Papa maximum minimum maximum
minimum maximum minimum maximum minimum
maximum minute
maximum never meant someone I couldn't
sell to hello just too adorable so what
do you what is it [ __ ] what do you
want what do you need I'm just looking
for some materials for these dolls that
I know Oh free it's what you know
there's one Christmas Shh max max stone
look at her you got it
sellers of stuff don't look at how much
this is throw blanket $200 I only have
ten dollars Derek's in trouble
okay enough Garak stand back and you
here charms don't work with me I donate
to green Oh save it we all donate to
Greenpeace you're using your powers for
evil and you know it
so either you pay 750 dollars for the
lot or write your best to get this all
on sale at Anthropologie it's gonna be
fine thank you
pleasure doing business with you love
your dress
got her mission accomplished all right
GPS set say goodbye to this house by
house
home sweet home ooh it could be a giant
shrimp with a mustache she'd be like hey
prawns wants it and that's aa guy what